en su camino hacia el mar la lava con su
método y la ceniza cubre las ciudades de
la isla española de la palma con su
temperatura de mil 100 grados celsius la
marea ardiente se desplaza ahora a 300
metros por hora según los expertos su
llegada al océano es temida por las
autoridades por las emisiones de gases
tóxicos y las proyecciones que podría
provocar una lucha titanes no entre el
agua y la lava esta lucha de titanes sus
temperaturas otras locaciones son
explosiones muy importantes en la
fragmentación también de sádaba que
puede ser disparado como proyectil sin
embargo la lava ha reducido su velocidad
y ahora los expertos dudan incluso que
pueda llegar al océano
el volcán también está emitiendo unas 10
mil toneladas de dióxido de azufre al
día pero las autoridades aseguraron que
por ahora no hay indicios de que sus
gases fueran perjudiciales para la salud
humana no hay problema con respecto al
allegro sulfuroso las mediciones que se
están realizando
no dan peligro para la salud humana
aunque no ha habido víctimas la lava ha
destruido 150 hectáreas de terreno y 320
edificios entre ellos muchas viviendas
abandonadas precipitadamente y por los
habitantes algunos pudieron regresar
brevemente a sus viviendas para salvar
parte de sus pertenencias todo lo que
empezó el domingo como
algo
fuera de ser algo bonito de ver pues al
día siguiente se convirtió todo en una
tragedia según el instituto involcan la
erupción de cumbre vieja podría durar
entre 24 y 84 días